>>Susan: I'd like to welcome Janna Gur to
come to our Authors@Google talk and I'm personally,
really thrilled to have Janna Gur here since
I'm a big fan and a big supporter of her cuisine
and her cookbook, which I, which I own and
which I think has many incredible recipes.
So, I was excited to have her here. And one
of the reasons I thought it was great and
such a good fit was because Google, as all
of you know, as foodies we have a tradition
at Google of having really incredible food.
And there's a lot of appreciation for good
food at Google. And we also have a whole group,
for example, we have Koogle at Google, which
is an alias that is the Google community that
celebrates Passover and gets together and
does a meal. But, Janna Gur has a very impressive
background, which I'd like to share.
She's the founder and editor-in-chief of the
Israeli food magazine, "Al Hashulhan," did
I say that right? She'll correct, she'll probably
say it correctly afterwards. She's published
28 books, and everyone should get them all.
[Susan laughs]
In Hebrew and in English. No, actually just
one. I, I can't read Hebrew, including her
first book, "The New Book of Israeli Food:
A Culinary Journey." And we have copies of
those books for sale and they're in the back,
and with that I'd like to have Janna come
up and introduce, start giving us some background
on her perspective. Thank you.
[applause]
>Janna: Hi, good afternoon. It's really exciting
and it's a great honor to be there. As a Google
user, Google is part of our lives, every day,
every moment almost, we're Googling something
and to be actually here to speak to you and
I know there are many other people somewhere
in the offices, hopefully listening to me,
but we, they won't be able to have the cookies,
by the way. We're gonna cookies later. Only
those who are actually here, so some people
that are hiding in the rooms, they're welcome
to join us.
Ok, thank you, Susan, for such warm introduction.
It's, my task is for next hour to try to explain
to you what Israeli food really is. And its,
it's a simple question, it's tricky answer
because it's food and cuisine in the making,
changing all the time, really finding it itself
all the time and since we're foodies here,
I hope, mostly the people who are listening
in, I decided to do it not through history,
not through long and theoretical discourse,
but through 12 dishes and ingredients. So,
it's gonna be the story of Israeli food in
12 dishes.
And the first one, sorry, I have to, wait
a second. I forgot that I'm not, read my password
again. Password, of course, taking up valuable
Google time.
Visitor's effect is what it's called, of course.
Of course another glitch.
Ok.
Thank God, could be really embarrassing.
[Janna laughs]
Ok, so here we have our first, the first thing
you actually think about when you say "Israeli
food," you think about falafel. So, I have
it here, proudly on the screen, but it's not
gonna be part of our Israeli dozen for a simple
reason because everybody more or less knows
what it is. "Oh, you're going to Israel, you're
gonna have a lot of falafel." So, sure there
is falafel. It's a very popular street snack
in Israel, but I think it's about time we
learned about other things which are Israeli
food and let's move to our next member of
the family, actually the first one.
And it's much, much less known. And it's very,
very ancient. And actually, I'd like to start
here because it takes us all the way back
to the Biblical times. And, you know, Israel
is a very young country, 62 years old and,
but we do have very ancient history it goes
all the way, thousands years ago. And this
product is, has actually very fascinating
story. It's called "freeki" in Arabic, modern
day Arabic, but it also appears in the Bible.
If you are familiar with celebrating the holiday
of Shavu'ot, the Holiday of Weeks, in three
weeks, and there is a very famous love story
between Boaz and Ruth. This poor widow from,
from Moab, and wealthy, older man and they
fall in love and they get married and they
become great-grandparents of King David.
And they're seduction scene is actually a
picnic; he's feeding her and he's feeding
her, in Hebrew, we say "savatla mea kehli",
any Israeli's here in the audience? Ok, you
remember it's "savatla mea kehli"? Pinched
her from the kehli. Kehli, in modern day Hebrew
means "a toast," but obviously Boaz didn't
have a toaster in the field, so it should
be something else. It should've been something
else, it's something that we, we call in Hebrew
also "karrmel" and it means green, cracked,
toasted wheat. Ok? So, why green toasted wheat?
Because, in the ancient times, we have this
very, very extreme heat waves in Israel during
springtime and the farmers were afraid that
the harvest will be ruined, will burn out.
So, they harvested some of the wheat early,
toasted it so it wouldn't spoil, cracked it,
and used it for cooking, toasted it. So, it's
a little bit like bulgur wheat, but it's green
wheat. And it's extremely, extremely, flavorful.
It has some very interesting smoky flavor.
It's popular in Arabic and Jewish cuisine.
Actually, it's a very ancient product that
survived thousands of years and remained in
Arabic cuisine. And Israeli chefs just fell
in love with it lately and it became one of
the trendiest dishes on Israeli restaurant
menus. So, this shows the continuation of
tradition from the Bible all the way to the
modern age and here, I think, we have --
[pause]
Ok, here we go. This is actually Boaz and
Ruth in the garden. And this is freeki pilaf,
made from one of our later, latest Israeli
cookbooks, very flavorful. I think you can
get it in the States as well, it's called
Green Wheat and this is the first member of
my Israeli dozen. And let's move on to the
next one.
We're still in the Biblical times, and any
ideas what is this beautiful fruit or vegetable,
anybody? Dates. That's right. Usually, I hope
people will say "olives" or "grapes," but
these are dates. Dates are one of the symbols
of ancient Israel. They are a member of the
seven species; the seven fruits and vegetables
with which the land of Israel is blessed.
You all know the expression, "the land of
milk and honey." Ok, now, the theory is that
the honey in the milk and honey is not bee's
honey, but date honey.
Date molasses, actually, and it's, it was
a very important sweetener in the ancient
times. Israel was covered with date growths
that looked something like that. Ok, this
is the harvest. The same dates we've just
seen, the red ones, that's the way they look
on the tree. So, as I was saying, the date
honey, the honey in the land of milk and honey,
is actually date honey, and that's what it
looks like. You can see it's brown, it's sweet,
it's less sweet than actual honey and it's
sort of caramel flavored. And, again, it comes
originally from Iraq, from Iraqi Jews were
the ones who brought it to Israel because
you all know that Israel is actually immigrant
societies, with people coming from all over
the world, each one bringing their own food
traditions.
So, the date honey, or as we call it in Hebrew,
"silan," actually arrived with Iraqi Jews
and today, well, you know bee producers, honey
producers in Israel really have a problem
because silan is winning, becoming more popular
than actual honey. It's cheaper to produce,
it's less sweet, it's, and it's very, very
trendy. So, I think in the States you can
find it maybe in Middle Eastern shops or in
stores that carry Israeli produce. You should
try it, it's great for glazing. It's actually
a little bit thinner, a little bit less sweet,
but it goes, again, all the way back to Biblical
tradition and yet another ingredient that
comprises what we now call Israeli cuisine.
[pause]
Ok. And now we come to something that everybody
knows. I mean, guess, anybody who doesn't
know what it is? Here?
This is, of course, hummus. And hummus is
something, oh my God.
[Janna laughs]
Ok. Hummus. Now, hummus is basically very,
very simple dish. It's chick peas, soaked
and cooked, tahini, lemon juice, water, condiments.
It's popular all over the Middle East. Everybody
has hummus for breakfast, maybe as a part
of mesa plate, but in Israel, hummus is actually,
I think I would call it a religion. Definitely
cult food. People rarely make it at home.
They usually go out to a restaurant. This
one is, for example, from a place called Hummus
Said in Akko, one of the most famous hummus
places in Israel. And it's very male thing,
you don't use knife and fork, you use, you
know, piece of very light, fluffy pita and
you mop it up.
And if you had real hummus, freshly made that
didn't spend any time in the refrigerator,
you will know it's an amazing, amazing dish.
Otherwise, I know many Jewish people in the
United States, know it as something you serve
at the bar mitzvah, and it's, it's, I mean,
really nothing impressive. This is not real
hummus. Real hummus you make and you serve
at once. It has to be warm because, you know
hummus in Hebrew is "himtza." Vinegar in Hebrew
is "hometz." It's the same root and this is
not accidental. Hummus spoils very, very quickly,
so to make industrial hummus, which what most
people in the States know as hummus, you have
to stuff it with antioxidants, add citric
acids, all kinds of stuff that spoils the
flavor.
It's actually very easy to make hummus at
home. The recipes in my book, but you can
find it anywhere and the secret is make it
and serve it. There is no other way and when
it's good, it's really, really amazing; fluffy,
flavorful, and actually there was a research
conducted lately that proves that eating hummus
actually releases endorphin in your mind.
So, it's the ultimate make good, make feel
well food. So, let's see if I'll be able to
move safely to the next step. Ok, here we
have two other famous hummus temples, I would
say.
The bottom one is Ali Karavan, the most famous
hummus in Tel Aviv, or actually in Jaffa.
By the way, invariably, best hummus places
in Israel are owned by Arabs and this is no
exception. Ali Karavan in Jaffa, it's very
rare, actually, to be able to grab a table
in Ali Karavan. Usually have your hummus standing
up on the pavement and balancing the plate
and the pita and a few months ago I brought
a bunch of really cool, important American
food writers to Israel on a culinary trip.
And my fantasy was to take all these sophisticated
New Yorkers to Ali Karavan and have them eating
hummus standing up and they did. And one of
them said, after the taste of the hummus,
he said, well actually, "masabacha," which
is a variation of hummus warm chick peas with
tahini and condiments that is really out of
this world, he tasted it and said, "Ok, and
now what I'm going to do for the rest of my
life?" And that was so, so great.
[laughter]
So, this is hummus and as I said, another
component, another cul-, much more falafel,
by the way. Falafel is sort of a little bit
thing of the past. We so still have falafel
joints, but they are dying out and hummus
is stronger than ever. About a year or two
ago, I think you might remember, Sharon, we
had this very short lived fashion of fancy
hummus with all kinds of creative toppings,
like bolognese on top of hummus, mushroom
ragu, it went away, thankfully very quickly,
because--
[laughter]
you don't fool with hummus. And one last thing
before I move to the-, to the new, to the
next item, my, actually during my first book
tour, a couple of years ago, I arrived in
Israel, to the States, and I had whole bunch
of things that I wanted to talk about, but
everybody wanted to talk to me about hummus.
And I couldn't figure out why until I realized
that there was this movie, "Don't Fool with--
>>memberfemale: Zohan
>>Janna: Zohan, right. So, everybody wanted
to know all about hummus and well, but hummus
outlives even trends like Zohan.
Ok, and now we have something else stuffed
in the pita. Now, you must understand in,
in Israeli food culture, pita is not just
a pocket bread. It's a way of eating; it's
a way of life. You stuff anything into a pita.
You can stuff the whole lunch into a pita.
You can stuff schnitzel, french fries, salad,
it goes all in a pita and it's actually sort
of movable, a movable lunch, moveable table.
But what we have here in the pita is actually
quite interesting and unique. And it shows
for me yet another aspect of, of Israeli food
culture. It is called "sabih." Anybody familiar,
except the Israelis here in the audience.
Anybody familiar here with the word sabih?
Do you know what it is?
>>membermale: [inaudible]
>>Janna: Oh, ok. Good. But you know what it
comes from? What is the history? Now, this
is really interesting. Sabih means "morning"
in Arabic. Sabah al khair, sabih is morning.
Now, it's actually combination of fried eggplants,
hard boiled eggs, hummus, which we already
know, and amba, a very spicy condiment coming
from Iraq and made from unripe mango. This
combination, this very delicious combo-, combination,
sandwich combo, actually originates as an
Iraqi Jews Shabbat breakfast. Now this needs
some explanation, I guess.
[laughter]
I guess you know that according to Israeli
religion and Judaism, you're not supposed
to do any work on Saturday. Everything has
to be done in advance. You cannot light fire;
you cannot do any manual work. On the other
hand, weekend is the time when you're supposed
to have your best meals. So, to solve this
problem, we have a lot of dishes designed
to be prepared in advance and enjoyed during
the Shabbat. We have very, very famous cholents,
you've all heard about; the Jewish Shabbat
casserole that stays all night in the oven
and then fills the house with all this hearty
smells and after you eat some, you can only
go to sleep, it's so filling and so heavy.
And that's actually a good idea because it
leaves nothing much to do on, on Shabbat afternoon
anyway.
[laughter]
You cannot go to movies, I mean, you know,
the observant Jews and the other thing is
breakfasts. Breakfasts are usually cold food
prepared in advance and thing that are, that
can be enjoyed cold. Now, Iraqi Jews would
have this spread grilled eggplants, hard boiled
eggs, hummus, and condiments on the table
and they would make their own pita with that.
One gentleman from Giv'atayim, a small town
near Tel Aviv, turned this sandwich combo
into an economic empire. He became very rich
sending this sabih thing and today can go
into a trendy restaurant and all-, order a
sabih and a focaccia. But the origin is Jewish
ethnic tradition; Jewish ethnic food from
Iraq. And this actually teaches us two things
about Israeli food. One, that it draws its
inspiration from Jewish ethnic cooking and
number two, Jewish ethnic cooking is much,
much more than what we know, especially in
the States as Jewish ethnic cooking.
It's not just gefilte fish, chopped liver,
chicken soup, etc., it's mostly food that
comes from all over the world because Jews
lived all over the world, in Iraq, in Iran,
in, in Morocco, in Persia, in Syria, in Hungary,
in everywhere they lived, they created some
sort of ethnic cuisine that all, at some point,
arrived in Israel. So, we sort of pick and
choose interesting traditions from various,
various places. I have another example here.
I-, by the way, this is interpretation by
a very famous Israeli chef, Yaron Shalev;
it's also called a sabih. I guess it has some
eggplants, even though we cannot see them,
it also has seafood and stuff. He calls it
sabih. It doesn't look like one, but it's
very good, actually. And here is another example,
very quick example of breakfast food of traditional
breakfast food. The Israelis, do you know
what it is? Jachnun. It comes from Yemen,
another place where Jews lived for thousands
of years and it's actually, its dough rolled
with fat.
And I know it sounds sort of disgusting, no
it doesn't, you like the idea, but think about
the croissant. What croissant dough, if you
know it? It's, it's, you flat out, you roll
out pastry and put a lot of butter inside
and then you roll it again and then you spread
it, so I can call it "Yemenite croissant."
And you can have it with also hardboiled egg,
something you could make in advance and grated
tomatoes. So, this is another example of breakfast
food that turned all Israeli favorite.
And now we're moving on to the next interesting
ingredient that is maybe one single most important
ingredient in modern Israeli cuisine, and
this is, of course, tahini. I have it here.
And it's made from sesame. One hundred percent
ground sesame; nothing else. Nothing else
should be there. Now, in Israel, we use it
for salads, for cooking, for dressing, for,
even for pastry. In the States, I think it's
largely misunderstood and used usually only
for hummus. I have to convince people to actually
make some use of it. In the end, if we have
time, we're gonna have a little demo on how
tahini spread is made. It's something that
you shouldn't buy readymade. You should make
it yourself from raw material. It's very,
very simple. It's 100% cholesterol free, it's
extremely versatile and we have here tahini
cookies, by the way. They taste magnificent
and those who stay till the end will have
a cookie, ok?
[laughter]
But I want to show you fifth, a few things
you can make with tahini. For example, these
are lamb patties with tahini dressed-, tahini
sauce. It's based on an Arabic dish called
"simia." In Arabic cuisine, tahini is often
used for cooking and for baking. It doesn't
break, it stays, it sort of hardens a little
bit and it gives very interesting flavor to
the food. This is fish filet with raw tahini
sauce. When I say raw, I mean tahini the way
it is, you can't really see, but it's like
brownish paste. When you use it with water,
mix it with water, you change the consistency,
we will see it in a few minutes. And what
else do we have with tahini? Ok, sorry, the
one you saw before, I want to go back to that.
It's really cool. No, please, back. Back.
Ok, this is tahini ice cream, ok? Now, it
sounds sort of strange, but do you know what
is halva? Ok, many people like halva. You
know that halva is sweetened tahini. It's
the same thing, but with added sugar or honey.
Now halva ice cream sounds great. So, this
is actually the same idea and what you have
on top, this little hairs, are shredded halva.
Amazingly sweet and fluffy, it's like eating
sweet clouds. It's really great. So, tahini
again, it's Middle Eastern staple, it used
everywhere in Middle Eastern cooking. Israeli
chefs adopted it. They use it in very creative
ways. We make all kind of flavored dressings
with that and you should learn how to use
it. It's wonderful substitute for mayonnaise;
100%cholesterol free, very healthy, very calorie
dense, but good calories.
Ok, and now we come to the next symbol of
Israeli cooking and that's the Israeli salad.
Now, again, we did not invent it. Israeli
salad is something that is actually chopped
salad, cucumbers, tomatoes, onions, sometimes
peppers, sometimes mint or cilantro, olive
oil, lemon juice, maybe radishes, but this
is actually the basic thing. It has to be
cut before you serve it. You don't make it
in advance because the tomatoes go all mushy.
Now, similar salads are found throughout the
Middle East, but I think Israel, I'm quite
sure that Israel is the only country in the
world where you eat salad for breakfast. Actually,
we eat it three times a day, for breakfast,
for lunch and for dinner. We sometimes stuff
it in a pita and we sometimes serve it with
tahini dressing. It's actually quite delicious.
And, as I said, Israeli, Israeli salad is
part of the Israeli breakfast and what sets
apart Israeli breakfast from all other breakfasts
is the fact that we eat salad. And it originated,
actually this tradition of having salad for
breakfast originated on a kibbutz; this, you
know, Utopian agriculture commune where everybody,
there was very much part of early Israeli
history.
And on a kibbutz, the farmers, the workers,
would go into the fields very, very early,
you know all, you all know what a kibbutz
is, of course, so I don't have to explain.
Ok, they would go to work very early, like
at 4 o'clock in the morning because it's a
very, very hot country and they would come
back around 8 o'clock when it's already quite
hungry because you put up, you know, three,
four hours of very hard manual work. And actually,
your breakfast would be almost your lunch.
So, they made, they ate whatever was available
and what was available was fresh vegetables,
of course.
They would, actually, the kibbutzni would
cut up their veggies by themselves and have
some simple dairy products, maybe some bread,
maybe some oranges, but Israeli salad was
there, in the middle, in the center. And today,
I don't think you can have an Israeli breakfast
without a salad. And I have here some nice
examples. This is a variation using very,
various kinds of tomatoes.
We have great tomatoes in Israel. I don't
know if you know that. I didn't know that,
but it turns out that Israel invented cherry
tomatoes, which I think quite important thing.
After ICQ, I guess.
And this is an example of a restaurant version
of an Israeli breakfast. You see some fancy
croissant at the background, even some sausage
and cheese and soft-boiled eggs and the salad,
right there. Very nice version of Israeli
salad.
If you go to Tel Aviv today, actually some
of the nicest meals you have, you can have
in Israel, in general, is breakfast. It's
very many leading restaurants serve breakfasts
and they make it, turned it into a really
delicious and elaborate meals. Very cheap,
by the way, and they sometimes serve it throughout
the day. They just call it breakfast, but
you can have it in the afternoon, also. And
there will be a salad.
Ok, and now I mentioned the fact that Israeli
salad was not invented in Israel. This little
fellow was, actually, I can show you the way
it looks. I mean, this is the raw material
and this is probably one of the only ingredients
that were actually invented, food ingredients
I mean, actually invented in Israel. And it's
known in the States as the Israeli couscous.
It's not couscous. We, in Israel, call it
"ptitim." Ptitim means "little flakes" and
it's actually toasted pasta flakes.
And to tell you the story about them, I have
to take you to another interesting period
of Israeli history. We're talking about early
50s, right after the State of Israel was founded
and there were huge, huge waves of immigrations,
like four, five times larger than the original
population of the country and the result was
that there was shortage in everything. And
food was rationed for awhile.
It became known as the Age of Austerity, or
"Tkufat HaTsena" in Hebrew, and there were
not enough meat, not enough fish, not enough
dairy products, and, of course, not enough
rice. And the story, the legend is that Ben-Gurion
himself, the Prime Minister of the State of
Israel, the first Prime Minister, came up
with an idea to produce pasta flakes that
would resemble rice. And that's why the first
version of ptitm was called Ben-Gurion rice.
Now, but it was not only rice shaped, it could
be couscous shape, or ball shape, like these
guys. And at some point, in the 90s, in Israel
you must understand, ptitim is something kids
love. It's a hit of the kindergarten lunch
menu, right? With a little bit of ketchup
on top. And in the 90s, suddenly Israelis
discovered to their very great surprise that
these ptitim have become the most trendy ingredient
in New York restaurants. So how did this happen?
It was reborn as Israeli couscous. I think
I found the answer. We sort of conducted a
little research on this subject a couple of
years ago and I believe I found the connection
how this came about. An Israeli chef, whose
name is Mika Sharon, you may know her, worked
in New York with a very famous chef, Don Pintabona,
it's either Tribeca Grill or Gramercy Tavern--
>>memberfemale: Tribeca Grill
>>Janna: Tribeca Grill. And they were friends,
actually. And he was having dinner at her
home on Friday night and she just made, you
know, a pot of ptitim for her kids. She wouldn't
even dream of serving it to, you know, this
important chef. He tasted it, he loved it,
he took away a package that looked exactly
like that to the restaurant and the next day
when she came to work, she realized that there
on the lunch special, made in some sort of
fancy risotto and called Israeli couscous
because on the package it says, "Toasted Pasta
Flakes, Israeli Pasta Flakes, Toasted, Israeli
Couscous," or something.
So he just showed them that and turned it
into Israeli couscous and this is, according
to my research at least, how the whole Israeli
couscous craze starts. Now, it finally becomes
fashionable in Israel as well. We say, "Ok,
if Americans like it so much, we probably
should have taken another look at that."
[laughter]
And, for example, this is, this was our cover
photo last summer. We did a big project on
ptitim and it's actually ptitim salad, Israeli
couscous salad and by the way, I had a meal
in Philadelphia in a very fancy restaurant
the other day and they were serving ptitim
for lunch as well, so I was very proud. Ok,
and now we come to something really, really
important. Before I settle on the name for
my book, the book of new Israeli food, I was
sort of trying out all kind of interesting
names for the book, and one of them was, "His
Majesty, the Eggplant and Other Vegetables."
[laughter]
Because this is the king of Israeli vegetables,
by far the most important one and what's nice
about eggplant is that it's so versatile.
It also has a chapter in this Austerity Age
that I was just telling you about, because
there were plenty of eggplants. And because
it's so versatile, and because it's so neutral,
you can do almost anything with it. So, we
had, like, faked chopped liver made from,
from eggplants. Later on, all the rage were
fried eggplants in especially Middle Eastern
restaurants, sometimes with tahini or with
yoghurt, but the current and most contemporary
and in my opinion, the best way to cook eggplants
is to burn them, or flame roast them. This
is the way to do it.
I remember one of my New York lectures, I
so convince somebody to do it that she tried
to make it in her New York kitchen and the
firemen came because they, all smoke detectors
were, were, buzzing, but if you have a barbeque
or if you have, if you open a window, it's
completely safe. You just put it on a stove,
it doesn't have to burn like that, but you
do flame roast it until the skin is charred
and soft and then you scoop out the flesh
and it has this wonderful, smoky, delicate
flavor that cannot be achieved if you make
it in the oven. Sorry, it has to be open fire.
Once you have this charred or burned or flame
roasted eggplant, you can do all bunch of
things with it. For example, you can make
the classic baba ganoush, which is flame roasted
eggplant with tahini. Or, if you are a trendy
Israeli chef, you will do something like that.
Ok, this is, I call it "baba ganoush deconstructed."
You take the whole eggplant and you slit it
open and instead of making a salad, you just
pour the ingredients on top of the vegetable.
Here you have silan, remember I mentioned
silan, some olive oil, some tomatoes seeds,
maybe some herbs, but actually it can be anything.
You can put yoghurt on top.
This is a very fancy and elegant way to serve
eggplants in your home, for example, when
you're entertain-, entertaining, you can make
like eggplant per person, slit it open, and
you can either put the ingredients on top
and serve them in the middle of the table
and everybody will eat their entrees, so to
speak, only make sure you don't eat the skin
because the skin is charred and not very tasty.
Or, you can remove the skin and just leave
the eggplant and then it could be something,
for example, like this. This dish is from
a very nice restaurant in Tel Aviv called
Sheila, and it's like quintessentially new
Israeli cuisine, you have, you can see the
eggplant on the bottom.
Ok, it's without the skin so it looks sort
of beige colored. On top you see the Israeli
salad mixed with raw fish, like sashimi style
raw fish, very sort of nouveau Israeli style
of serving fish. And at the background, the
grayish sauce is actually tahini based, so
you have like, the whole speil of Israeli
cuisine in one little, pretty dish.
Ok, and we're moving to the next trendy item.
Somebody goes, "Yeah," do you know what it
is?
You're just hungry, I think. You didn't have
lunch.
[Janna laughs]
Ok, this is shakshouka. Shakshouka, now shakshouka
actually is another example of Jewish ethnic
dish that became first very famous in Israel
and then sort of took even the world tour.
It comes originally from Tunisia. As I mentioned,
the Jewish traditions from all over the place.
Actually, it's very, I think the next photo
may be more telling. Now this is really another
kind of, shakshouka, wait a second.
Ok, so what you do basically, to make shakshouka,
you prepare a very, very spicy tomato sauce
with peppers, with baharat, which is a typical
Middle Eastern spice mix, sometimes you can
add eggplants, you can add sausage, whatever
you like. Once the sauce is cooked and spicy
and flavorful, you break some eggs on top
and you wait until they are set. You can wait
for three minutes, for five minutes, depending
on how you like your eggs. That's it.
And there was this guy named Bino Sadok, who
created a place called Dr. Shakshuka in Jaffa,
and you serve, of course, you have to serve
it in the same skillet with a lot of crusty
white bread to mop up the sauce and he made
shakshouka so famous, I don't think there
is a tourist coming to Israel who go-, who
doesn't go to Dr. Shakshuka. But today, you
can actually find all kinds of shakshoukas,
not necessarily with tomato sauce. For example,
this is also a shakshouka. It's shakshouka
with spinach and goat cheese and it's delicious
and light. The same idea, but without the
sauce, you just wilt, in this case, it's leek
and pinach in spinach and then you break the
eggs and you crumble some feta cheese on top;
very famous, very popular breakfast dish in
Israel in one of the fancy restaurant breakfasts.
Another option, this is shakshouka actually
with ratatouille. You can take the ratatouille,
if you have ratatouille left in the fridge,
or givech, some sort of stewed vegetables
you can warm them in your skillet, break some
eggs on top, scramble cheese, and call it
shakshouka, even though it really isn't. And
this is another version of spinach shakshouka,
very-. If you go to Israel, to an Israeli
restaurant, you'll definitely find at least
one version of shakshouka. Actually, I remember
on early 80s, when the Israeli cuisine, the
sophisticated Israeli cuisine was taking it's
really first baby steps, we had this very,
very famous restaurant called Killeen, owned
by Haim Cohen, a very, very famous Israeli
chef, and he was basically preparing French
cuisine, very sort of Mediterranean, maybe
a little bit, but not Israeli.
He wouldn't serve any Israeli food because
they were considered too commonplace, nobody
would pay lot of money to eat hummus, or tahini,
or stuff like that. And one day, for his lunch
specialty, he prepared shakshouka with foie
gras, with goose liver, and it was a hit and
he felt encouraged, and the next day he prepared
kabab with tahini for the special and audience
loved it and we can say these are, this is
where the Israeli cuisine really starts getting
interested. Because when we start relating
to our local traditions and from them drawing
inspiration as well as from Jewish ethnic
cooking, this is how it all actually happens.
Ok, and now, for the first time, I have something
that is really considered Jewish. Ok, and
I brought it, also because, well, we all love
chicken soup, but also because many people
think that when they go Israel, they're gonna
get to gefilte fish and chopped liver paradise.
And they're very much surprised that there
is so little of that in Israel. We do have
some, what we call Ashkenazi food, but it's
very, very rare. Actually, in the world, when
you say Jewish food, you automatically mean
this kind of chopped liver, gefilte fish and
stuff, but this is actually representative
only small part of Jewish cuisine; Jewish
cuisine from Eastern Europe and Russia.
The reason that it became synonymous with
Jewish food in general is because of massive
waves of immigration of Russian and Polish
Jews coming to the States and to Canada in
the beginning of 20th century. Many of them
went into food business, opened up restaurants
and delis, and made this food world famous.
Many dishes, by the way, they invented here.
For example, when I was born in Riga, former
Soviet Union, and that, the Ashkenazi land,
so to speak, and I can tell you I've never
had bagel with cream cheese and lochs in Riga.
I don't think even we know what cream cheese,
I mean, there was, there is no cream cheese
in this area. This is an American invention,
and neither we had Reuben sandwich. It's 100%
American, but I guess these dishes were prepared
in these delis, in these restaurants, still
are, and they became synonymous with Jewish
food, but that's the whole beauty of it. There
is nothing wrong with it.
Make, this is important to understand, that's
how cuisines evolve. That's how Israeli cuisine
evolves. That we take inspiration from various
dishes, we play around with them, we fuse
them with something else, and this is actually
very good example and I have a personal story
about this. This is Jewish chicken soup. And
it's, do you know what is this orange thing
in, in the middle? What does it look like?
It's pumpkin, yeah. Now, those of you who
know how to make Jewish chicken soup would
say, "Pumpkin? What is, what is pumpkin doing
there?" Well, the thing is, when my book was
first published and it was reviewed in American
press and I got, I must say, I'm glad to say,
very nice, favorable reviews, one of them,
though, said that my Ashkenazi dishes are
not to be trusted because they're not authentic
enough and as an example, my recipe for the
chicken soup was given.
Now, it's important to emphasize, I'm not
a chef, I'm a food writer and the majority
of recipes in my book are not my recipes,
they are recipes by famous Israeli chefs or
very traditional recipe. This is my chicken
soup. I mean, I really know how to make a
chicken soup and she said, this person, that
it's not authentic enough because she said,
"Janna says use as many vegetables as you
like; leeks and celery and pumpkin." And she
said, "And pumpkin? My Boba is turning in
her grave. You do not put pumpkin into chicken
soup." And, well, I was sort of a little bit
irate in the beginning, but then I decided
to check other Israeli recipes for chicken
soup and surprisingly enough, almost all of
them had pumpkin.
So, at this point, I sort of, I was almost
glad about this critic because it sort of
gave me an insight on what Israeli cuisine
is because we may call it Jewish classic chicken
soup, but it is already influenced by other
Jewish chicken soups that do have pumpkins
and a bunch of other stuff. For example, this
one, this is Moroccan vegetable soup that
you serve over couscous and it has pumpkin,
of course, and it has zucchini and it has
other stuff. And so, what happens because
Israeli society is very, very mixed, it's
not just immigrant society, but intermarriage
is actually the norm.
Almost, every Israeli you meet, you ask where
he or she is from, they would say, "My father
is from Iraq, my mother is from Hungary. My
father is from Yemen, my mother is from Morocco."
So, when there is this kind of intermarriage,
automatically there is cross-over on the plate.
So, schnitzel and couscous during one lunch,
chicken soup that you can't really know where
it comes from because it turns out that every
Jewish food culture has its own version of
chicken soup. And pumpkin, sort of, cross
over from Balkan or Moroccan tradition right
to Ashkenazi one and I think that's the whole
beauty of that. So, thank that, I don't remember
her name, this critic that gave me this wonderful
insight.
And now we come to malabi, another ola ka
dashni immigrant, this time from Turkey, it's
a very sweet, lovely pudding made from water,
corn flour, milk, and rose essence. It started
out as street snack that you would buy from
street carts and it developed into a very
fancy dessert. That's how it would look like
in the restaurant. The red sauce, the raspberry
sauce goes on the bottom instead of on top
and then you have the actual pudding and on
top you have some nice little fruit compote,
an example of street food that turned into
a restaurant dessert. And this is malabi cheesecake;
the same idea, but applied to cheesecake flavored
with rose essence.
And now we come to the last one of the dozen.
I just couldn't resist bringing this photo,
which, in my opinion, is the most beautiful
photo in the book. And it's actually interesting
because of; these are of course, pomegranates.
And this is a pomegranate grove and, you know,
it's interesting with symbols. My book has
pomegranates on the cover and two other Israeli
cookbooks, very, sort of, you know, cookbook
coffee table books, published in English,
also have pomegranates on the cover. And frankly,
and Sharon will correct me, we do not use
that many pomegranates in cooking. I mean,
it's, we sometimes sprinkle them on top of,
on top of tabouli salads.
I mean, people buy them because they are so
beautiful and you, they look nice in a bowl
on the table, but during recent years when
the nutritionist discovered that they have
all these amazing antioxidant qualities, somebody
became crazy, all of us became crazy for pomegranates
and we started to grow them commercially in
Israel because ten years ago you would mainly
find pomegranate trees in the backyard, like
one or two trees. Now, we have this amazingly
beautiful pomegranates groves I think that
my, for me it looks like the, you know, the
fruit of the Garden of Eden.
Something that was the Adam and Eve are tempted
to eat and we are rediscovering, actually,
things that we can do with pomegranates since
we so, have so many and for example, we can
make this. This is one of my favorite chef,
his name is Erez Komarovsky, one of the most
interesting and creative Israeli chefs. Here,
he makes a beet and pomegranate salad. A wonderful
combination, same color, different texture,
different flavors, if you have pomegranates
in season, try it. It takes two minutes; I
think it's one of the best salads in the book.
And, here, and at this, where I want to finish,
I go back to Jewish ethnic cooking, which
for me, is one of the most exciting aspects
of our food culture. As I told you, Jews have
lived all over the world for centuries, for
thousands of years. Wherever they lived they
created their own cuisines and we have all
of them now in Israel. It won't last long,
by the way. It will be gone in a matter of
generation, too, because this is time consuming,
labor intensive style of cooking and these
cuisines actually represent cultures that
do not exist anymore.
Think of it. There are no more Jews left neither
in Iraq nor Iran, Syria, Persia, so these
are endangered species, but they still do
exist and those of you are interested in ethnic
cooking and have access to these wonderful
cooks, should learn how to make a few recipes
and try to preserve them for future generations.
What we have here, by the way, is the lady,
I forgot her name, I'm afraid, I know, her
name is Rachel, actually. And she's from lovely
Persian restaurant, in Kfar_Saba, a little
town near Tel Aviv, called Gohar, and the
dish she's holding proudly in her hands are
lamb patties in fesenjan sauce. This is Persian
sauce made from walnuts and pomegranates molasses
and served with fresh pomegranates and cilantro.
Amazing dish, now existing in Israel, going
back all the way to thousand years ago when
it was first created in, by Persian Jews and
for me this sort of closes the circle, the
cycle of what we call Israeli cuisine, which
is cuisine in progress. We don't even know
where it's going, but one thing I can tell
you, those of you who haven't been to Israel,
or who have been, we're having some great,
terrific, fresh health food and it's only
will get better with time, I think. Now, if
we have time for little tahini demo and you
have energy, I'll be happy to oblige, if not,
I'm ready for questions so we can do both
things simultaneously. And thank you very
much.